okay okay we're playing back in your  back yard out back in here I'm backyard  let's do this I got this all [ __ ]  skimpy ass anyway it's your boy  psychobabble and let's count here right  here you know keeping a row there's a  switch have you come to nelson seeking  your death delete follow me that's a  [ __ ] are we why have you [ __ ] it you  have a look  oh wait you guys what the [ __ ] has gone  on here  what's out okay good good good let's get  out of here not chef here we go antihero  in the Mojave he almost makes you wish  for a new clue that guys get the heck  out of here I'm getting shot at this is  [ __ ] not [ __ ] [ __ ] dogs birthday  is that him  me and carmine that's my we'll do our  okay this hey I don't lose an IM family  I can't come on foxy I Jesus we won't go  quietly the Legion can count on that  f-fuck is my uh  sneeze that arias fuxee on up there  howdy what's the word